the president is planning a summit next
month with Russian President Vladimir
Putin they are likely to discuss Syria
and Ukraine along with Russia's possible
re-entry into the g7 group of major
industrialized nations the president
said he's looking forward to the meeting
bianna golodryga is here with the
potential implications for the summit
beyond a good morning good morning the
president has wanted this meeting for a
long time the president his closest
advisors say Russia must play a major
part in the geopolitical climate today
something that assured a rattle US
allies National Security Advisor John
Bolton met with President Putin in
Moscow to iron out the summit details
the two discussed Russian interference
in the 2016 election something Putin
still denies and something the president
Trump won't acknowledge the two
presidents have met at least twice
before the most recent of those on the
sidelines of November's asia-pacific
summit now this new meeting will likely
take place just a few days after mr.
Trump attends the NATO summit in
Brussels where a prime concern among
NATO members will be continued Russian
deterrence one issue NATO is
particularly concerned about is its
joint military exercises with the US
Putin like Kim jong-un if you'll recall
has called these exercises of
provocation it's not yet clear what mr.
Trump is looking to accomplish by
sitting down with Vladimir Putin that is
a big question
Boulton dismissed critics who say Putin
is trying to drive a wedge between the
u.s. and Western allies saying that a
meeting between the two leaders is in
the interest of the United States we
should be getting more details about
this meeting today later today
Thank You bianna ways good to have you
at the table